hey everyone is Fairs rich Turner sorry
and calm and in this video I wanna give
you a pneumonic on how to remember the
five categories of drugs that you do not
crush as a nurse okay so what are those
five categories we have the same relief
extended release control release
enteric-coated and long-acting so how
are you going to remember those five
categories okay remember this mnemonic
seniors erroneously crush enteric-coated
laxatives this mamani helps me remember
the five categories because a lot of
times requesting medications for
patients who are older because they have
difficulty swallowing so seniors and
seniors tend to take laxatives because
as you get older and the GI system they
slows down they tend to have
constipation ones so they tend to have
laxatives lot and you would never crush
enteric-coated laxatives like a dulcolax
ec so each part of the word helps me
remember the category so seniors s are
abbreviation for senior is fr for
sustained release all they may see SI
for sustained action erroneously er
stands for extended release you may see
it as XR as well crush the CR seems for
controlled release can sometimes eat a
cd4 controlled delivery enteric-coated
of course is for enteric coated EC and
in laxatives LA is for long-acting you
may sometimes see an abbreviate
abbreviation XL so if you're ever
wondering if this medication is a
sustained action or release or something
like that just look at the name of the
drug because typically you'll have like
a drug name that will say like get
trough la we know that that's d'etre
long-acting so we can't cross it the
huddle is this pneumonic helps you out
don't forget to check out my other
videos on some mnemonics like the in
forum video where I give you a new mom
somehow remember
categories of insulin along with the P&A
sometimes and then the pneumonic on how
to remember contact isolation thank you
so much for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos